well today marks the start of the
biggest shopping weekend of the year
that's right folks more than 164 million
people plan to shop between Thanksgiving
Day and Cyber Monday the long weekend
kicks off the holiday shopping season
shoppers will each spend an average of
nearly a thousand dollars CBS News
financial contributor Mellody Hobson is
in San Francisco melody this used to be
the day where everyone went out shopping
right after Thanksgiving into tonight
into tomorrow morning now we're seeing
only 35% of Americans say they're gonna
shop on Black Friday they're calling it
gray Friday instead so what gives well
what has happened is for sure the day is
not as big as it used to be but it is
still really big so 115 million people
will buy something tomorrow that's a big
number it's the biggest shopping day of
the year but the numbers are down and a
lot of that is driven by the fact that I
heard one analysts say retailers want it
to be a holiday marathon not a one-day
sprint and they'll be offering deals all
through the season as they happen we've
gotten very used to specials and
discounting and that's changed the
prominence and the attractiveness of
Black Friday melody but what is this how
much is online shopping cannibalized
brick-and-mortar retail we see malls
closing I think a quarter of us malls
are supposed to close in the next 15 or
20 years we see the demise of a lot of
brick-and-mortar retail and local
neighborhoods how much does it there's a
role there's certainly been a big effect
however keep in mind 85 percent of sales
during this holiday season will occur in
a store 85 percent so the number is
still really huge the brick-and-mortar
retailers are trying to extend their
business online because online is where
the growth is online is growing 15 to 20
percent a year and we know the one that
dominates online is Amazon half of all
online sales occur just with Amazon so
brick-and-mortar is not dead even though
we have absolutely seen a major change
the lines are blurring and at the same
time online is growing very fast so
Melanie let me share a new CBS poll with
our
audience here nearly 40% of Americans
dread holiday shopping so how are they
the stores trying to get people back
into them because I'm one of those folks
who cannot you need the crisis I need I
need to be enticed exactly they are
pulling out all the stops they're trying
everything research online buy in-store
research and store buy online return in
store
I mean curbside pickup you name it they
are trying everything fully stocked bars
are privatized they are really trying to
create and meet you where you want to be
to have the experience be what you want
it to be and they're trying and melody
overall sales though are expected to be
up this year right I mean the
president's been touting the stock
market he's been touting consumer
confidence all year and with good reason
we are seeing an increase in confidence
does that mean that by the end of the
year we are going to see an increase in
spending compared to last year analysts
are saying three point six to four
percent increase in this year and so
we'll see but all retailers won't do the
same somewhere on the ropes some will
thrive what are you gonna be buying
melody I just started and I've got a
long list all right oh yeah three-piece
suit thank you very much Happy
Thanksgiving
Thanks